today on the matt walsh show after
tornadoes devastated parts of the
country on saturday the left insists
that the disaster could have been
prevented through legislation is that
true can we pass laws that will stop
tornadoes we have to deal with that
today also major retail chains beg
congress for help in dealing with the
surge in crime i'll explain why they
should be basically out of luck and the
catholic diocese says that it's a sin to
try and change your gender the media is
treating this like breaking news but
isn't that what every competent
christian believes and with jesse
smallett's conviction there is a
competition to see who can take his
place as our nation's chief race hoaxer
one blm supporting doctor seems to be
auditioning for the role we'll talk
about all that and much more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
well i'm on the road again and uh you
know what that means i always have my
trusty relief band by my side not by my
side actually on my wrist and especially
here in california the the opportunities
for nausea are are many for various
different reasons so i have my my uh
relief band but i'm not the only one who
suffers from nausea did you know that
one out of three americans regularly
suffer from nausea we've all experienced
that horrible feeling whether it's in
the backseat of a car staring at your
phone uh or you know after you had one
too many out with your friends one night
even just a little bit of anxiety you
know during during work whatever it is
you know that nausea can really ruin
your day which is why you need relief
band it's the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness uh
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness chemotherapy and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
it provides all-natural long-lasting
relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed with the holiday season upon us
there's never been a better time to give
the gift of relief and make sure your
loved ones are nausea free right now the
relief band has an exclusive offer just
for my listeners if you go to relief
band and use promo code walsh you'll
receive 20 off plus free shipping and a
no questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com use our
promo code walsh for 20 off plus free
shipping
living as we did up in the woods in
pennsylvania before we moved out to
nashville we never had to think much
about you know tornadoes pennsylvania
sees its share of twisters but tennessee
has significantly more though both
states are dwarfed by kansas texas
oklahoma et cetera and the tornado tally
so after a year in tennessee it was not
completely out of the ordinary when the
tornado warning started blaring on our
phones early saturday morning this past
saturday morning around 3am
we had a tornado watch before we went to
bed which means that conditions are such
that there could be tornadoes the
warning comes in when actual funnel
clouds have been sighted and you need to
seek shelter immediately
it's always disconcerting huddling in
the basement listening to the winds that
sound like mack trucks speeding through
your yard
but that's all it was in our neck of the
woods lots of wind and noise and some
down power lines and then some scattered
tree limbs and that was that was
basically the extent of it our neighbors
especially to the north and west of us
were not so lucky around 20 separate
tornadoes
including one massive one that cut a
path across some they think 200 miles
and uh ripped through parts of tennessee
kentucky arkansas missouri hitting
hitting kentucky the hardest over 100
people were killed the majority in
kentucky and the lion's share of those
deaths were concentrated in one factory
a candle factory where dozens of workers
were killed when the factory was totally
demolished by the storms in fact almost
the whole town of mayfield where the
factory was located was destroyed
images of the devastation looked like
you know the aftermath of some kind of
aerial bombardment during wartime the
daily wire was on the scene interviewing
survivors you can you can hear them tell
the story in their own words and see
some of the images take a look at this
never in my life seen destruction like
this never
first tornado warnings uh
we had a siren right there so super loud
but at that moment i started getting
mattresses out i was just ready right by
the closet that i planned on it was the
most centered part of the house so uh it
was making fun of me you know what i
mean but it's better safety sorry and
then we went out on the front porch
because i've personally never seen a
tornado and
next thing you know
got real calm and then i heard something
like a freight train and you know i've
always watched documentary stuff so the
whole all the power went out and i seen
like the tornado looked blue from the
electricity and it was probably about
two streets over that way that's when we
seen it
so i immediately run in
the gentleman's laying in bed over there
so
i bust this door down tell him to get up
tornado's coming he jumps in the shower
and we run over here uh get we get up in
the closet and pull mattress over us the
whole house starts shaking uh you hear
things breaking and i was just praying
the whole time you know and uh it was it
happened so fast and it was calm
everybody got out make sure everybody
was okay and the first thing you know we
thought of was getting out and helping
so that's truly horrifying and there's a
there's a sickening sort of uh
helplessness that you feel when you're
in the path of something like this we
had just a very very small taste of that
uh where we lived
because you know that you're at the
mercy of nature and if things decide to
hit directly where you're sitting
no matter how many precautions you take
you're probably doomed
when you consider the force and the
magnitude and the boundlessness of
nature
it becomes all the more not only
grotesque but absurd after the fact
when the political forces in our country
attempt to turn these
natural forces
into a political issue
that's exactly what happened here as
usual with bodies still buried under the
rubble the media and politicians set out
to make ideological hay out of the whole
thing by tying the tornadoes to of
course climate change and claiming that
that we could have somehow prevented
saturday's disaster through well-written
legislation
there could have been laws written to
stop tornadoes that's the claim here's
uh president biden
does this say anything to you about
climate change
or do you have conclude that these
well all that i know is that
the intensity of the weather across the
board
has some impact as a consequence of the
warming of the planet
and the climate change the specific
impact on these specific storms i can't
say at this point i'm going to be asking
the epa and others to take a look at
that but the fact is that
we all know everything is more intense
when the climate is warming everything
and obviously it has some impact here
but i can't give you a quantitative read
on that
yes we know that um we know that the
climate change caused this
i can't say how
or to what extent or offer any proof
but you know just go with my general
statements anyway
it it it had we don't know how but it
but it happened
actor mark ruffalo last seen using
cutesy pet names for child rapists and
kenosha was more direct tweeting quote
this is what hashtag climate catastrophe
looks like
it's only going to get worse from here
now it's time to fight for our suffering
and despairing youth yeah we have to we
have to fight uh tornadoes
let's come up with our game plan
to fight back against tornadoes
rachel vinman a woman with an
inexplicably large following said
climate change what does it look like
this is absolutely heartbreaking and
it's a direct result of climate change
believe me i know it's tempting to
scream yell and question why people are
so slow to accept reality but we must
have conversations with skeptics that's
another thing that will stop tornadoes
conversations
noel scoville another woman with an
inexplicably large following
wrote sorry kentucky maybe if your two
senators hadn't spent decades blocking
legislation to reduce climate change you
wouldn't be suffering from climate
disasters if it's any consolation
mcconnell and rand have effed over all
of us too now she tweeted that by the
way uh
no noelle scoville did tweeted that
early in the morning on saturday
so it was like the very first thing she
thought when she woke up to the news
that a hundred people were buried under
rubble across
you know three different states the very
first thing she thought was oh this is
going to be a great way this is this uh
i could i could get a little dig in here
against the republicans and mcconnell
and rand paul
the media of course chimed in with
explainers like this one from cnn how
the climate crisis is affecting
tornadoes and then this from washington
post a warming world could add more fuel
to tornadoes scientists say
and so on you get the idea the consensus
from all of these sources
is that natural disasters like tornadoes
happen because of us
these people believe or at least they
want us to believe which is not
necessarily the same thing
that there is actually legislation that
can be written
laws that can be passed to stop
tornadoes
so when they look at a at footage of an
f5 tornado
and when most of us see footage like
that we see
a force of nature
we see nature in all of its in all of
its terrifying deadly
um
you know
essence but what they see with the
tornado is a policy failure
tornadoes are policy failures that's how
they see it
now let's let's be clear about something
here
um
that view to the extent that it's held
sincerely
is straight up superstition okay it's on
the level of like a primitive tribesman
who thinks that he can stop the rain or
make the rain start or or whatever
influence the weather by dancing around
a fire enchanting certain things
in fact it's worse than that it's far
worse than that because at least the
primitive tribesman has an excuse to be
ignorant
of the science
he does he doesn't have access to that
information he is making sense of the
world with the information that he has
available to him the modern climate
change alarmist should know better and
often does but he spreads this nonsense
anyway
now here are some facts to keep in mind
on the issue of climate change and how
it affects tornadoes
first of all if natural disasters were
getting deadlier
there would be a very obvious reason for
that which has nothing to do with
climate change
there are more people on earth so a
deadlier
catastrophe is one right that kills more
people and if there are more people
around then that means that more people
can die
which because more people are will be in
the path of any given disaster
there are
twice as many people in the midwest
today
as there were in the 20s for example
which puts twice as many people in the
path of tornadoes
and yet
so that's if the if natural disasters
were getting deadlier that would be the
reason
yet amazingly what you find is that in
fact a lot fewer people are actually
dying in this way natural disaster
deaths are
at historic lows not highs
in spite of the fact that there are so
many more people around
as andrew folet who's a former nasa
scientist he explained this weekend in a
very enlightening thread on twitter
in fact
the deadliest day for tornadoes in
american history still
was in the 20s
1925 not even 20 years after the model t
was first introduced
so not a lot of time for um for fossil
fuels to
be creating tornadoes right
and yet 700 people died in basically the
same region where 100 just died from
tornadoes and again there were fewer
people
populations were more spread out less
dense than they are now
and yet the disaster was deadlier much
deadlier
why is that well that's because
it's because of the kinds of modern
innovations that the left blames for
natural disasters
those those innovations that get blamed
for natural disasters are actually
saving millions of lives from natural
disasters
by the way the deadliest hurricane in
american history hit galveston
and guess what year 1900.
and we know about hurricanes as far back
as the 1600s that were killing thousands
of people we can't go back farther than
that because there was nobody around in
this part of the world keeping reliable
records
that's the other problem with comparing
weather events across centuries
we've only been keeping track of these
things reliably for a comparatively
short amount of time and so it's very
hard
nobody has any idea how many tornadoes
hit the north american continent in the
year 1350 for example or how bad they
were or how many people died from them
we have absolutely no idea we can't
possibly know
did a tornado hit
this continent in on on march 7th
you know in the area where kansas is now
in the year
1272. do you know the answer to that
nobody does
there was no one around keeping records
of it
there are people around but they weren't
keeping reliable records that we can use
now to trace the weather
and yet you hear things like oh it was
the worst storm in history
well how do you know that
what that always means is worst storm by
certain metrics we think
since we started keeping track a few
decades ago
that's what worst in history means when
it comes to weather events
remember something
um the earth is enormous
and ancient
it didn't begin at the dawn of the
industrial age
despite what you may have heard
go back to the year
700 million bc
and there were weather events going on
far more extreme than what we
experienced today
and the climate was changing and the
climate changes were far more drastic
and devastating
just there were no people around to be
affected by
go forward to the year 770 000 bc let's
see let's say
and you'll see the earth getting
battered by all kinds of extreme weather
events
same in the year 7000 bc
and 1000 a.d
in the year 1550 in 1650 and 1721 and
now in 2021 and yet after these billions
of years of history
where the earth has endured one
catastrophe after another we we step
into this chain of events in modern
times and surmise that it's all our
fault
and that we can actually stop it
by writing words on a piece of paper
and having a bunch of politicians sign
it
the amount of ego required to believe
this is almost
impossible to fathom
and yet at the same time
i can see why it's appealing in a
certain way
because i go back to that feeling of
dread when the tornado warning sounds
and you'll you're huddle you're huddled
in your your safe place that they tell
you to go to and you've got your kids
and your families there
and it's only safe so long as the
tornado doesn't get too close to it
right
it is it's scary to be so powerless and
vulnerable
in the face of these things that we
can't control so there's a comfort then
in climate change hysteria
that's one of the great lessons of the
last couple of years especially is that
there's a comfort for people find
comfort in hysteria
believe it or not
because it convinces you that you can
conceivably control the uncontrollable
and that you are not at the mercy of
forces beyond you
but that's all a lie
it's an illusion
stop fooling yourself
and face reality
now let's get to our five headlines
well you know it's a strange american
custom at least uh in some family
certainly mine to never use the front
door you know and we're one of those
families where we always go in through
the garage
and uh
maybe when there's guests over we let
them use the front door because we don't
want them to see the disaster zone that
our garage is but uh you know the
garages are statistically speaking the
most frequently accessed entry to the
home but they're often overlooked
even though they're the place where
people keep all their important things
they they walk through it and everything
else which is why you need the myq smart
camera by chamberlain the only smart
camera optimized for the garage brought
to you by the leaders in garage door
opener technology with features like
live video streaming recorded events
motion detection and a two-way
communication system right from your
phone you can make sure that your garage
is secure 24 7. if you pair it with the
myq smart garage control you'll never
have to worry if you left the garage
door open you can check it see it close
it all from the myq app from anywhere so
there's convenience there's security
there's safety you've got all that mixed
in one so what are you waiting for give
the gift of a myq smart garage camera to
tech lovers this season if you act now
you could say 46 for a limited time by
entering walsh at checkout on myq dot
com slash walsh that was wall should
check out on myq dot com walsh to say 46
off keep an eye on what's happening in
and around your home's busiest entryway
with the myq smart garage camera it's
the only smart camera optimized for the
garage
all right so we are back uh if you're
wondering about the the change of venue
here yet again we're back in california
uh back in uh for for a few days back in
covid stan
and you know you always
you try to erase it from your mind when
you come to one of these places if you
live in a sane part of the country
and uh you come to one of these places
then you leave you try to erase it from
your mind so it's always kind of a shock
to the system coming back to a place
like this whether it's california or
you know new york or somewhere like that
where where you know you can't walk into
a building without being
accosted by 50 people yelling at you to
put your mask on
and i go into like at the hotel here i
go into the uh
into the elevator and there are there
are markings on the floor
one in each corner
for where you can stand when you're in
the elevator and i look at that
and i want to believe
that people are not actually using those
markers and standing on the
on on their little spots on the floor
and they're right like in the corner i'm
actually surprised see they're in the
corner but they're facing out i'm
surprised they're not facing in so that
each person you you stand in the
elevator in your corner and you face the
corner like like five-year-olds that
have been put in time out
so they didn't do that they do let you
face out and so you can see forward but
you have to stand in your corner
and i want to believe that everyone has
the same reaction i do when you go and
you see stuff like that you just kind of
scoff at it laugh at it but this is
california and i bet there are a lot of
people who get in there and they get in
there and they get in their spot
that's what i'm betting and the thing is
under normal circumstances
if you weren't telling me to do it
that's basically what i would do in an
elevator anyway and not because of covid
but when i'm in the elevator i want to
be as far away from the next person as i
can
and just just out of the principle of
anti-socialism
the ant of being anti-social
anti-socialism is a different thing
which i also hold that principle um so
based on that principle you know i
that's kind of what i'll do
but then when you tell me to do it now i
don't want to do it
now i'm gonna stand right in the middle
of that thing on purpose i'm gonna i'm
gonna cozy up next to someone which i
would never do in an elevator but just
because you told me not to now i will
that's the american spirit
um
it's also you know childish but you know
what we need we need a little bit of
that kind of childishness in the world
today in this country we need that
we need some of that spirit you know you
could go too far with it but we need
some of that spirit where you're telling
me to do it and so i'm not going to do
it
all right on the subject of covet fauci
is out uh now doing some very direct
fear-mongering to parents of young
children nothing new there but now this
is a direct appeal to the parents of
young children specifically uh up until
the last few weeks or so when it came to
kids he he would mostly just he wouldn't
talk about it of course he was never
being honest and and actually saying to
people listen your kids are going to be
fine this really isn't much of a threat
to kids he was never saying that instead
he was just remaining silent but now
that there is a vaccine to sell
now he's doing this direct appeal
and this direct fear-mongering
uh but in the midst of his fear
mongering here the play here he he makes
the mistake of telling the truth in the
midst of the fear mongering listen to
this if your child is five years of age
and older please get them vaccinated we
need to protect
the children this idea that children are
not vulnerable at all is not so george i
mean certainly statistically children do
not get as severe disease as the adults
particularly the elderly but if you look
at the number of cases of children now
well over two million children from five
to eleven have been infected they've
been over eight thousand to nine
thousand hospitalizations and well over
a hundred deaths
so okay
let's run the numbers there the numbers
that he that he just gave us okay so
these are from
fouchy
um based on what he just said
that would be a mortality rate for
children in that age bracket of
0.005 percent a 0.005 percent mortality
rate
so that would be a fraction of a
fraction of a fraction of a percent
is the mortality rate
and that actually overstates it
by a considerable amount because those
two million cases that he quotes
they don't count the very many kids who
had it and weren't tested because they
had no symptoms
and there's no way for us to know how
many kids fall into that category but it
would be it would be reasonable to
suspect
that the actual number of cases of covet
among that age bracket is uh is you know
is
considerably higher than 2 million
two million times two or four or who
knows
so at the most the way to put this is at
the absolute most the mortality rate for
kids in that age bracket is point zero
zero five percent
and at the most at the absolute most
in the hospitalization rate is point
four percent
and even this doesn't take into account
things like comorbidities and that sort
of thing
which are not as common among kids but
they they of course do exist
and this is all in the context of trying
to convince us that we have to go and
get our kids jabbed with the vaccine
when the risk level is that
it's a risk level
i mean it it exists that we can't say
that there's no risk
but when the risk level from uh from a
standpoint of pure common sense
and being able to function in the world
right being a functional human being
the risk level that small there's really
there's no reason to respond to it at
all
because there are so many other if if
we're going to start measuring fraction
of a fraction of a fraction of a percent
type risks especially as a parent
then you're never going to let your kid
leave the house you're not going to let
them ever do anything
as we've talked about many times you
will never put them in a car
because the risk there is greater
statistically
even if covet goes away you're never
going to bring them around people
because the risk of flu is greater for
them in that age bracket
never going to do anything
um
so
it
when the again when the risk level is
that small
you have to decide are you are you going
to is your life gonna revolve around
that are you just gonna continue to live
your life
and it's
there's something really especially
sinister reprehensible
first of all to pray on a parent's fear
like this
because we know as parents
it's one thing just to step back from
the situation to look at the numbers
look at the data and kind of
evaluate it objectively but as a parent
when it comes to your own kids
it's it's it's very easy for fear to
take over
and it's hard to make these reasonable
calculated judgments sometimes
as parents we all we also we also have
these special fears things that we worry
about that are almost certainly not
gonna happen but you for whatever reason
it plays on your anxieties in a certain
way and you
you worry about it way more than you
need to
for a lot of parents i think it's
something like kidnapping a lot of
parents are very worried about the kids
going to get kidnapped
even though that almost never happens it
almost never happens that a child is
kidnapped by a stranger now we're
talking about custody disputes and that
kind of thing then yeah it does happen
but the the fear that uh someone's gonna
just some stranger is gonna roll up in a
white van and take your kid it all it
almost definitely will not happen
it almost never happens it doesn't make
any sense to worry about it at all
really
because the risk is that small but as as
a parent these are you just once you
here's what you do as you start
imagining these situations in your head
in your in your anxious state you kind
of call them into being
and then you start worrying about these
these things that you've imagined
and now we've got pharmaceutical
companies and fauci as their spokesman
preying upon that and it's really pretty
sinister but then also keep this in mind
this this could really get children
killed eventually and i'll tell you why
because it's only a matter of time
before a pandemic hits that actually
does target kids we know historically
that obviously has happened
polio
just one example
so it's inevitable that event hopefully
it won't be soon but eventually there's
going to be there are going to be more
pandemics in the future there are always
going to be pandemics
and
it just so happens that this one
for the most part leaves kids alone in
terms of serious uh reactions to it but
that's not always gonna be the case
eventually a virus is gonna come along
that really will target kids
in a you know in a very specific way but
the problem is
that now that we've been lied to so much
about it
a lot of people aren't going to believe
it
when you've got the fouchies of the
world coming out and say oh this is this
is coming after your kids many people
are going to say well that's what you
said last time
so it's the boy who cried wolf scenario
except in this case it's not sheep that
are at risk it's your kids
all right let's move on to this uh major
retail chains like best buy target
nordstrom footlocker and some others
many others in fact have now crawled to
congress begging for help during this
surge of crime and looting
organized retail theft as they're
calling it which is looting
um
the word looting and also the word
rioting have become politically
incorrect now because of the way that we
associate them with rightly so with blm
and so now it's organized retail theft
is what we call it
and representatives of all these major
chains wrote a letter to congress which
says in part
uh leading retailers are concerned about
the growing impact organized retail
crime is having on the communities we
proudly serve
which is why we strongly support the
bipartisan and bicameral integrity
notification and fairness in online
retail marketplace for consumers act
inform is the acronym they're going for
that's why they stretched for it this
important legislation will modernize our
consumer protection laws to safeguard
families and communities from the sale
of illicit products and we urge its
quick passage
there is no simple answer to stopping
organized retail crime for the or the
sale of counterfeits but key to stemming
the tide of these growing problems is
transparency if a customer buys a
product from a local retail storefront
or ecommerce site it is broken or
otherwise defective the consumer knows
exactly who to contact there's
accountability in the current
environment uh
blah blah blah we need this to happen
it's time for congress to modernize our
consumer safety laws so consumers retail
employees and businesses are not targets
of organized retail crime and dangerous
counterfeit products
it's time for congress to act is what
they're saying
and i can see why they want help
of course i can this this is destroying
them they're shutting down locations
uh
chains like walgreens walgreens has
basically been chased out of
places like san francisco
target is having a hard time too they're
having to limit hours
lots of other things that are happening
because of all this crime
and that's why they want help
but here's what i would do if i was in
charge
if it were up to me
and sadly at this point it is not until
i complete my theocratic fascist
takeover of the world which will happen
um
but if it were up to me
i would say to target best buy nordstrom
footlocker all the rest of them here's
what i would say i would say we will
help you
right we're glad to help you if
you have not catered to the blm mob and
the woke mob
thereby celebrating the very criminality
that you now want to be protected from
so we'll take a look at your social
media accounts and we'll take a look at
your public statements and all the
different marketing and stuff that
you've done
and as long as you haven't done any of
that
no hashtag blm they're putting the black
square up anything like that
we stand with george floyd
as long as we find none of that then
then we'll help you out
which is just another way of saying that
if we're up to me i wouldn't be helping
any of these companies because every
single one of them
have
uh have been cowed before the mob
that has now turned its sights on them
and is destroying them
so you got to live with this this this
is your problem
now you want help i mean what did you
think was going to happen
well i know the the mark the plan from
the marketing geniuses at these
corporations
is that hey if we say uh yeah let's go
blm if we if we cater to them if we get
out the pom-poms and cheer them on then
uh then they'll they'll pass us over
like the angel of death on passover this
is our you know our wokeness
is the lamb's blood on the door
and it didn't work out that way
because in this case the angel of death
visited every single house that had that
had the lamb's blood on the door
and you know why because the angel to
keep to continue with this metaphor the
angel of death is realizing that oh okay
well these are the people who will do
what i say
these are the companies that will let me
get away with anything
these are the these are the
organizations that will bow before me so
these are the ones i'm going to pick on
so you're on your own
have fun with that
let's see what else we got here
um from the washington post
this is here's a headline that's not
really a headline it says a catholic
diocese in michigan has instructed its
pastors to deny baptism confirmation
other sacraments to transgender and
non-binary people
unless they have quote repented possibly
the first diocese in the united states
to issue such a sweeping policy about
those who identify with a gender other
than their assigned sex at birth
um
and let's put a lot of air quotes around
sex assigned at birth because we know
that that phrase makes no sense at all
your sex is not assigned at birth
they're not this is not something that
the doctor decides on they is it is
observed and noted sex noted at birth
sex observed at birth not sex assigned
at birth no one is assigning anything
uh as i've said before they're not it's
not like there's a they're pulling out a
filing cabinet and uh saying okay well
this one's a boy let's grab a penis out
of the penis filing cabinet and uh and
put it on there that's not the way it
works now sex assigned at birth that's
it sounds like that's how it works so i
didn't know anything and i was coming in
like a blank slate i had no idea how how
humanity comes to be and what the
birthing process is like or anything and
i was some sort of alien let's say
landing here one of uh one of uh demi
lovato's friends
landing here
and i heard about sex being assigned at
birth that's what i would imagine
i would imagine that oh well this is a
species where they are born sexless
with no kind of genitals or anything and
then all of that stuff is sort of
affixed on to them through some kind of
process
maybe it's a lottery process who knows
that's not how it works anyway where
were we um the guidance issued by the
diocese of marquette also stipulates
that transgender people may not receive
communion in which catholics believe the
blood body and blood of jesus christ are
truly present in most circumstances they
cannot receive the anointing of the sick
which is meant to provide physical or
spiritual healing to those who are
seriously ill the guidance was issued in
july but only recently sparked a debate
after a prominent priest and advocate
for lgbtq catholics shared it on twitter
the document says the experience of
incongruence and one's sexual identity
is not sinful if it does not arise from
the person's free will nor would it
stand in the way of christian initiation
however deliberate freely chosen and
manifest behaviors to redefine one sex
do constitute such an obstacle
this is yet another example where the
media uh i always love these stories
about the catholic church and media
because they have no idea
any story that deals with religion these
are these are godless heathens
and uh they haven't been inside a church
since they were probably three years old
if they went inside one now they burst
into flames so they have no idea what
they're talking about and they act uh
surprised and shocked and they make
headlines
out of these policies of the catholic
church or teachings of the catholic
church that have been in place since
forever right and that that
this is the case everywhere
all dioceses let me i have news for you
media anyone on the left it's even worse
than you think because all diocese have
or should have anyway this exact policy
because it is a sin
to reject your sex to mutilate your body
to deny your biological
selfhood
these are sins
of course they are
just think about now
this idea
that you could be born in the wrong body
and uh and that this is a problem that
has to be corrected through surgery
hormones whatever
this makes no sense on a purely
scientific biological level
so if we're engaging with this from a
secular perspective that makes no sense
at all born in the wrong body what are
you talking about
in that case you are your body that's
all you are so what what is in the wrong
body exactly what do you mean
my brain is in the wrong body your brain
is part of your body you might as well
say that you have well this is not the
right left arm i should have a different
left arm
it makes no sense from a scientific
perspective no sense
but from a religious perspective
which is how the catholic church is
going to approach this
or again should be approaching it it
makes even less sense
and it's not just that it makes sense
it's also it's blasphemy
because now you're saying that if
someone made a mistake here what it was
god
god accidentally what did it infuse the
female soul into a male body
it was a mistake on the celestial
assembly line
now what you are saying is that god made
a mistake
a rather severe
serious mistake of putting the wrong
soul into the wrong body
and so you are what you're saying is i
have to correct god's mistake
god gave me this self but this is the
wrong self
i reject it and i'm going to try to make
a new one
of course that's sinful that's pride
that's blasphemy that's sacrilege that's
that's all of the deadly sins wrapped
into one package
and this is uh this is not my opinion of
of the christian approach to this
subject this this is the there is no
alternative
because the only alternative would be to
either take
remove god from the equation entirely in
which case this thing still makes no
sense or it's to make god it's certainly
something much less than
omnipotent
and omniscient all-powerful and
all-knowing
now you have a god who's a sort of a
what a bumbling idiot
there's no idea what he's doing when
he's when he's uh fashioning people
i made you in your womb i i you know i
knew you before you were born and
apparently this is a process rife with
mistake
all right
what else do we got here
so steven spielberg's west side story
adaptation was released this weekend and
uh it flopped i just wanted to mention
this huge marketing push behind it rave
reviews lots of hype
nobody cared
had a a 10 million opening
and that's for a 100 million movie
directed by the most famous director
probably in the history of hollywood
that's a big failure and the media as as
always with these kinds of things when a
movie is all this marketing everything
and and
what what really
sends them for a loop is that they told
us because like i said it got rave
reviews they had like 98 on raw tomatoes
or something
and so they told us that the movie is
good
they specifically told us that it's good
and we should watch it
and and nobody is
and that makes them confused and scared
and and also really angry and so they're
all these articles now what went wrong
why isn't anyone watching west side
story let me let me let me explain i'll
tell you why okay
number one
it's really three reasons
number one the movie is woke
uh there's of course it is
because every movie is now every major
hollywood movie is they they all are and
they all will be for the foreseeable
future so we know that going in
uh but we know in this case there's a
trans character played by a non-binary
actor and they made a big deal about
that
uh they made a big deal about how
inclusive the movie is and all this kind
of stuff
and uh
now that's how they marketed it
they're talking about the diversity of
the cast and it's inclusive
i haven't seen the movie i don't plan on
watching it so i don't know how
in your face the wokeness actually is
when you watch it but that's how they
marketed it
that's the foot they decided to put
forward here and the audience doesn't
want that nobody in the audience wants
that nobody now there are certain
segments of the audience that might
applaud the pc movies in theory
but they don't watch them
nobody actually they might sit back
maybe for most of them aren't really big
movie fans anyway they're not the type
to go to the theater so they'll sit back
and they'll kind of oh isn't that so
nice that's that's inclusive they're not
going to watch it
because it's boring it's not real like
we want exciting stories
we want stories that
uh that
have
something real to say something of
substance
and something of substance cannot be the
sort of lecture we might hear in an hr
you know job orientation seminar about
diversity and inclusion and tolerance so
nobody wants it that's the first problem
uh second problem is west side story as
a movie is corny as hell and it's just
not a good story
now i admit i saw the original movie
like once i'm not i'm not a musical fan
so i admit that i'm so maybe i'm not a
good judge here
um
but it struck me it's a much cheesier
romeo and juliet and and maybe the music
is good for a musical i won't try to
judge that part of it and i admit with
musicals it's like i'm trying to get
into the story and then and we've got
good guys and bad guys protagonists
antagonists and i'm getting into the
story and then they all break out into a
choreographed dance number and it takes
me out it's the the fourth wall is
totally shattered right then
it's a fourth wall breaking moment
to the it's it's it would be like if
i could see on camera
the buffet
table on the back there where the extras
and everything are having a snack okay
that's what it's like for me in terms of
breaking the fourth wall it takes me out
of this and makes me realize again oh
this is just a story
and especially when they're supposed to
be
these rival gangs intimidating
and now they're doing ballet
dances in the middle of the
middle of the alleyway to intimidate
each other
uh so that's that's a problem
and and then the third problem is that
uh people are just tired of the remakes
and rehashes
they're tired of them so we've seen all
these things before if you want to watch
west side story we all have access to
all of these movies
because everybody is subscribed to 50
different streaming services so we all
we all have immediate access within the
blink of an eye in the speed of light we
can access like every movie that's ever
been made in history
and so if you're if you're just giving
us the same thing we already have then
what incentive is there to watch
so
that hopefully explains that
uh finally one other thing to note here
there's a
there was an article
about police in in the uk and uh how now
this is in the times
uk uh newspaper about how police in the
uk are now going to start
logging you know in their records when
they arrest someone if they arrest a
rapist a sex offender someone committed
a violent sex offense they're going to
log that person in the official records
as a woman
even if it was a man if the person
identifies as a woman
and so what
because they if if someone is a rapist
and and rapes a woman
what they're saying now is well we're
going to respect their self-identity
because yes this is a violent rapist but
we wouldn't want to hurt his feelings
or interfere with his perception of
himself in any way whatsoever so now
we're going to see this it probably
increased this surge of
women rapists
um and there are women rapists out there
but it's not nearly as common as male
rapists
and now we're gonna see this surge
because because we're respecting the
self-identity of of uh women rapists now
bring this up because jk rowling the way
that i came across this news is jk
rowling
was trending on twitter because
everybody's mad at her again
and uh she had shared an article about
this
and was critical of it
and she she wrote war is peace freedom
is slavery ignorance is strength the
penis individual who raped you is a
woman
and all the left is very upset and
they're complaining about it and
attacking her as always
i just wanted to say about jk rowling
now
you can look at what she's done over the
last few years and being so outspoken on
this issue on the trans issue
and you could say
well she's not risking anything because
she has a zillion dollars and what does
she what does she have to lose
and i get that
but i think it's more accurate to look
at it from the other way and say what
does she have to gain she has nothing
personally to gain from this in fact she
has everything to lose
which is why
when you look at other people of her
stature
and people who have more money than her
or less
like anyone in that realm real really
famous influential wealthy people
almost none of them
i think she might be like the only one
who is really speaking out on this issue
the way that she has been
that's because
yeah you could you could look at it like
i've got all this money what do i have
to lose
but what do we see with rich people
whenever they get cancer
they are the quickest to fold
because they look at it at the other way
they see i have only to all i can do is
lose
i have nothing to gain by standing
strong here
and people as they get more successful
they have more money there is this
retrenchment that kind of happens and
you get more cautious and you figure
okay i've found my groove i always money
coming in i've got all this respect i've
got everything in the world
and so any risk i take it's one thing
when you're still scrappy and you're
kind of climbing up the ladder and you
got to take risks you know and then and
then everything you do it's you could
lose everything but you could you could
also gain everything when you get to the
top
then you start thinking i'm already at
the top so any risk i take
um i'm i've made i'm at the summit now
so if i start jumping around and taking
risks and everything all i could do is
fall down the mountain i can't go any
higher and that's what most famous rich
people do
uh jk rowling isn't doing that i think
she deserves a lot of respect for that
it's it's it's actually very brave and
the other thing that
confuses me about this
is that from what i've noticed
the right is not really rallying around
jk rowling the way that
we often do with celebrities who speak
out and say something we agree with
now now you could point out that jk
rowling probably disagrees with
conservatives on every other issue
if she knew who i was
she would probably hate my guts which
would hurt me deeply as a fellow
best-selling children's author and maybe
that's part of the reason why i'm
defending her here because i you know
have that connection with her but yeah
she probably would hate my guts if she
knew who i was she would she would send
me to the gulag i get it
but this is one of the most important
issues of our time she's stayed firm on
it for years
and it's not like she just said one
thing
one simple statement
she has been repeatedly outspoken and
spoken about it written essays and
everything spoken about it quite
eloquently and insightfully
and yet there hasn't been this rallying
point around her to the same extent when
when you look at i mean we on the right
we rally around kanye west or uh you
know who was the what was it cardi b or
one of these female rappers they say
they they utter one sentence we agree
with
we hate everything else they say and do
they utter one sentence we agree with
not even on a central core issue it
could just be uh i hate taxes or
cancel or you know i don't know about
this cancel culture thing i i don't
really like it and that's it and and we
are smitten okay we got we have uh
hearts in our eyes and and we're seeing
stars and everything and we want to
rally around that person and hold them
up as a champion
um
even though they didn't even say
anything all that interesting
and usually within a couple of days
because they've got the wrong people
rallying to them so they'll apologize
and back down
yet rowling on this central core issue
where she actually spoke about it
eloquently insightfully and powerfully
uh and and and stuck to her guns
she's not getting the same support from
the right which i find really really
interesting
when you're at the pump these days it
may seem like all downside and uh and it
is for most people unless you have the
get upside app
uh this is an app where you can make and
many of my listeners are already making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time you fill up just download the
free get upside app in the app store or
google play right now and here's a bonus
if you use promo code walsh you get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents a gallon
cashback
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free and use promo
code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cash back on your first tank
there are people who i talk to who drive
a lot are making 200 300 a month cash
back
and there's no catch there's no fine
print it's really simple you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands it's that simple that easy and
again it's all upside so just download
the free getupside app and use promo
code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cashback on your first tank
that's code walsh
all right let's get now to the comment
section do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
uh erica says simone biles winning
athlete of the year such a slap in the
face to all the other athletes who
actually had major wins at the olympics
including one of her own teammates who
performed even better than expected and
won the gold medal in the individual all
around there are many other olympians
who also had huge victories all of whom
are more worthy of athlete of the year
it didn't bother me that simone pulled
out of the olympics but it does bother
me that she gets recognition over all
the other olympians including her
teammates who did perform their best and
who were successful
uh yeah this is what i said about simone
biles from the very beginning
i thought what she did in pulling out
was cowardly but if that's all it was if
she had simply pulled out and quit on
her team and everybody reacted to that
in a in a common sense kind of way in a
rational way and we had said well that's
too bad that's disappointing but uh that
was her choice and that's what she did
and then we all moved on
it would be fine i never would have said
a word about simon biles
but
as is often the case
it's the reaction
that turns it into an issue
it's the reaction it's when the media
comes around and says
oh you know what no but you have to
celebrate this this is actually
courageous
and again if they if if their response
had simply been oh let's be sympathetic
for her we don't know what she's going
through you know
let's not judge her too harshly once
again i probably would have no problem
with that i would have said anything
okay fine
you know all right she's she's a still a
young woman she's the only one just a
lot a lot of pressure on her shoulders i
get it
but when you tell me that it's virtue
when you tell me that it's courageous
when you tell me i have to celebrate it
okay now i have to speak up and say no
and i think that is the problem so
you're right with that
and uh as far as being awarded athlete
of the year it's all virtue signaling
right nothing is authentic anymore in
our culture
our women of the year our men our
athletes of the year are quitters
it's the it's the death of realness
of authenticity
it's uh it's a real uh existential
catastrophe you might say
okay bear of divinity says hey matt's a
big fan of the show when they accuse
johnny the walrus of being anti-trans it
sounds like that they were not only
engaging in gay erasure but also
transphobia towards trans species
your thoughts i think you're exactly
right about that
um
you know there are people who have said
that really it should be lgbtqia and we
need to add the w on the end for for
walrus and i think i i think i agree
with that
uh by the way a quick update on that
story though
amazon did remove me from the lgbt
category as i know you heard if you
listen to the show and that was a human
rights abuse it was a hate crime against
me
as an lgbt author
and as a gay as a as a as a a straight
gay icon
um
but
when uh when i think it was lgbtq news
or one of these other one one of these
gay news sites reached out to amazon for
comment
they said that yeah
i was taken off of the lgbt
category but they're not going to take
me off the site because i have not
violated any guidelines so i'm safe
there i'm actually not going to get
taken down from amazon because i haven't
violated guidelines which technically is
true because you know the book doesn't
actually say anything about it doesn't
technically directly say anything about
transgender people or lgbt
so
skating behind the technicality which
means you can go to amazon right now and
buy giant walrus
cindy says i love how matt breaks his
showdown into four soothing predictable
sections
predictable
you're banned from the show but thanks
for listening
vitor says
um how does their relationship work out
funny thing ellen page is actually now
divorced
the love of my life lasted about three
years i guess yeah i didn't realize that
so we played the clip of on stephen
colbert's show
ellen page
doing her emotional tearful monologue
about jessie smilet shortly after he
first perpetrated the hoax
and she has a picture of her and her
wife i guess she just got married and
she calls she says mike pence wants to
stop this from happening this is the
love of my life and then a few years
later she's divorced
so it's not funny but it was a little
bit it well and of course they're
getting divorced by the way
her wife is a lesbian
who married a woman
so
she wasn't in the bargain to marry a man
this is the this is part of the the
narcissism part of what makes all this
sinful this i'm going to control my
identity i'm going to be who's who i say
i want to be
because um
not only is it a rejection of biology
not only is it a rejection of god's plan
for you but it is it's also a rejection
of of your role in your family and in
your marriage
and if you have kids like what you're
saying to all these people
is i'm going to take if you're say a man
and you have a wife and kids and you've
got parents
and you've got siblings what you're
saying to your family now is i'm going
to take your son from you and your
brother and your husband and your father
i'm taking him away
and in his place i'm putting uh this
person
and i am requiring that you play along
with this now charade
that old person is dead now
in fact even say his name is to deadname
him
i'm taking him away from you sorry kids
you don't have a daddy anymore you have
two moms
is that a sin oh yeah for sure
the bind administration's
unconstitutional vaccine mandate is not
doing very well in court not only has
the osho mandate received a nationwide
stay but the u.s senate has just voted
48-52 against biden's federal mandate
however the issue now goes to the
democrat-led house who will likely push
it through
so this is on top of the biden winter
covid plan where they've extended the
mass mandate they're talking about
possibly vaccine passports to travel
domestically so that's what's at stake
here and that's why we have to continue
to fight back uh our collective voices
have never been more important in the
fight for freedom and now is your chance
to add your voice to the fight if you
haven't signed a petition against
biden's vaccine mandate i need you to
head on over to dailywire.com do not
comply right now to add your name we
need to send an overwhelming message to
the buying administration we uh we're
last i checked we're over 750 000
signatures we want to get to a million
we will get there we need your help go
to dailywire.com
do not comply right now and after you do
that
well do that after the show give it one
more segment and then you do that and
then the next step is to go to
johnnywalrus.com and pick up my best
selling beloved revered celebrated
lgbt best seller
johnny the wallers
um it is available right now as and and
amazon as we just talked about is not
banning it so it's on amazon which means
that we can keep it it's been kind of
living in the top 10 going back and
forth we got it all the way up to the
top five
uh but you know it's the longer it's in
the top 10 the funnier this entire thing
is that's really that's my one of my
primary sales pitches but maybe the more
important detail here is that we're
fighting back against the uh wokifying
of children's books so go to
johnnywalrus.com right now and pick up
your copy of the book now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel a man by the name of dr
ty winters
now what you should know about dr
winters is that he is a very woke doctor
that's important context here he calls
himself a social justice warrior in his
twitter bio and needless to say he lists
his pronouns which are he him by the way
he also includes the hashtag fight with
your privilege hashtag fight with your
privilege
i think what he means is probably fight
against your privilege or fight your
privilege but the phrasing makes it
sound like he's exhorting us to fight
with it meaning
use it like a weapon he might say fight
with your sword like fight with your
privilege use it as a weapon
it sounds like that sounds like what
he's saying which ironically is exactly
what he does
now the rest of his page is littered
with all kinds of woke graffiti he's
also affiliated with something called
the tour for diversity
in summary dr winters is very concerned
with racism and microaggressions and
diversity intolerance and all the things
that you're required to care about these
days
and wouldn't you know it what a strange
turn of events recently dr winters had
an interaction with somebody
who just so happened to reinforce all of
these talking points it's crazy how that
happens it's pretty pretty common
coincidence the people who spend most
their the most time talking about racism
are usually the ones who happen to
encounter the most absurdly racist
people in real life
only we never see those encounters we
just have to take their word for it
strange how that happens
so the doctor tweeted this on friday
along with a selfie where he appears
wearing a full suit with a badge that
says doctor
the tweet says
walking down the hallway when stopped by
someone
excuse me you're housekeeping right i
replied no but i can try to help you if
you need something the person looks down
at my badge oh you're a doctor sorry you
look like the custodial staff
um
my god i mean i shouldn't be laughing
it's terrible that's a terrible rate the
racism is out of control
because that obviously is the not at all
subtle point here the other person was
clearly racist and that's why they
assume that a black man must be a
janitor and the tweet quickly went viral
with lots of leftists sharing it and
expressing outrage i mean they were they
were flabbergasted
they knew racism was bad in america but
but it's even worse than they thought
how could white people be so racist that
they'd think that a man in a full suit
at a hospital is part of the custodial
staff just because he's black
well let me clear up the mystery for you
um luckily uh white people are not that
racist because this never happened
they only
the only thing that would make this less
believable is if he claimed that the
person poured bleach on his head and
shouted this is a maga hospital
nobody is going to i'll tell you this no
one is going to think that a man in a
full suit and tie at a hospital is a
janitor
that's not the janitorial uniform
have you ever seen a man in a suit push
a mop like have you ever you ever
witnessed that anywhere i never have
is this supposed to go the reverse way
too i i wonder could i walk down the
street as a white man
with like no shirt and no shoes and a
ripped pair of jeans covered in mud
and somebody runs up to me and goes
excuse me sir you're a heart surgeon
right come with me quick my dad's having
a heart attack
are these the kinds of assumptions that
dr winters thinks white people make
but as always with these hate hoaxes the
hoaxer accidentally reveals that he has
never been around an actual white racist
in his life
which is good news
because if he had he'd know that even
racist white people are aware that
non-white people are doctors you
couldn't possibly spend any time in a
hospital anywhere in the country without
encountering that reality
it is a very common thing to see
non-white doctors
also even the most racist person in the
world wouldn't look a black guy in the
face and say you look like the custodial
staff
no one is saying that
come to think of it nobody would say the
phrase custodial staff in regular
conversation
maybe if you're a doctor and you only
hang out with doctors
that's how you speak
but but no one is saying that i've never
heard a normal person in regular refer
to the custodial staff
and normal people also don't refer to
janitors at hospitals as housekeeping
these are all things that make sense in
the privileged elitist mind bubble that
dr smallette lives in
speaking of which the really surprising
thing about the smallet case
was just how lazy the hoax was this is
always the case with these hoaxes
he planned it out
and invested in it financially but he
showed very little attention to detail
especially when it came time to execute
the hoax
so for example the police chief in
chicago who at the time the police chief
who arrested smilet was on the news this
weekend talking about one of the many
red flags that tipped him off this was
all a hoax there were a lot of red flags
he goes through but here's here here's
the one that for him was decisive listen
to this well looking back on it the the
part about the news but what but what
really struck us oddly because i at that
time i had been a cop 30 years 31 years
and so i had been in the detective
division working homicides a lot uh back
when i was a sergeant what really struck
us all
was the fact that he got attacked on the
coldest night of the year during the
polar vortex i remember the polar vortex
i was here for a trip yeah the planes
were frozen the pipes were frozen
insanely cold yeah so nobody was out
there were no people walking their dogs
late at night but i tell you one thing
that really tipped us off that there was
a problem
if somebody gets jumped like that and
okay so let me back up a bit he went to
a subway sandwich shop at like two in
the morning to get a sandwich okay
that's fine
he comes back gets attacked in a
hate crime supposed hate crime and
during all this scuffle they poured uh
bleach on him and all of this
when he got up and went into his
apartment building he still had that
subway sandwich with him
that doesn't happen so smallett went
through all that trouble recruited two
nigerians
went out in a polar vortex
but didn't think to drop the sandwich
or even to scuff the sandwich up a
little bit to make it look like it had
just been in the middle of a violent
struggle
the sandwich was pristine apparently
this is the nicest sandwich anyone's
ever seen from subway normally all
subway sandwiches look like they just
got jumped so that made this sandwich's
immaculate condition all the stranger
for the police
the point is that the hoaxers don't
bother to attend the details
dr wintersmolet ii
didn't take a few minutes to come up
with some credible lines of dialogue to
put into the mouth of his fictional
antagonist
he just typed this out in a dash and hit
send
fight with your privilege that's exactly
what he's doing just like smolette
just like all the hoaxers
they are so insulated from actual strife
and struggle and certainly from actual
bigotry that they uh they fetishize it
and yet they can't act out these roles
or invent these stories believably
because they've never encountered these
sorts of people that they're inventing
and for that they should be very
grateful
but instead their privilege makes them
bitter and weirdly resentful
and this is what it drives them to
which is why i must say that dr ty
winters is just the latest hoaxer
certainly not the last on this show to
be canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire on today's episode search
and recovery efforts continue after a
series of deadly tornadoes
the u.s suffers record inflation and the
prosecution rests its case against
gillane maxwell
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire